[Music]
[Music]
well in the past Alden was very
underutilized so this just didn't feel
comfortable and the room was always
locked up anyway so then we wonder how
do we improve album soothe our students
who grow to love it and use it
[Music]
Design Thinking is as human centered
approach in which we seek to empathize
challenge assumptions and soft problems
in a creative and innovative way to come
up with the design solution we will have
to press understand that students and
teachers my team and I decided to
observe several students for day and I
was responsible for serving Jillian a 14
year old student you can try the less
successful I definitely love the
projects cuz I feel like we care about
work others
meanwhile I was observing nd at the 10
year old student this is any particular
subject that you actually like now with
the data collected we are ready to draw
up a user journey map based on our users
coming up with a user journey map helps
to put ourselves in their shoes now we
can see what the students and teachers
see feel what they feel and experience
the room as they do and the instruction
is a very quiet board most of the time
you will say no I don't know I'm not
interested
[Music]
now we are ready to define the needs of
our students and teachers with this data
we now know that visibility is important
to the users when students can see at
their work they are more likely to be
inspired comfort is important we must
have the right kind of furniture colors
and lighting tones and we must have
exciting tools to engage students
[Music]
ideation is for getting everybody to try
ideas any ideas in design thinking as no
hierarchy there's no judgment of ideas
and everybody's welcome to bring an idea
to life we must first test it out
creating quick graph and scale down
prototypes is an important part of the
process journey right they go through
before the X move on to the technical
inspection after we are fine-tuned at
prototypes it's time to gather out
students for their feedback I think
maybe my inner layer under the table
shouldn't they have mas workspace oh so
you want more storage space ideas are
only successful if you work for the
people who use them this allows us to
see solution to the eyes to know what's
working and what's not
why
[Music]
today our design space has become a
popular hangout spot for students
now everyone can see everything clearly
from outside inside on one end of the
room with the addendum
Furniture is modular to Hobart Exeter
the open concept encourages open
communication and collaboration students
also have free access to the 3d printers
laser cutters and many different types
of low res prototyping materials this is
one of my inventions I can still make a
lot more
I love Thursday because this [ __ ]
Thursday I wish every day was Thursday
we are happy to have made a real
difference to our students and teachers
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you